my name is clay Moffat I'm a filmmaker
in San Tan Valley Arizona in my
professional film career I guess I've
made probably five or six short films
and currently working on my third
feature film right now as director on
average I shoot a feature film in about
three or four days I do all the writing
directing producing and editing myself
I'm able to support my family and keep
throwing money and income into films by
having a full-time job I actually manage
a pizza restaurant and I work 55 hours
every single week in addition to seeing
my wife raising my kids and living that
lifestyle and also producing films so
there's only 24 hours in a day and I
stretch it thin the secret is caffeine I
would say the secret and a lot of people
tell me this too is the secret is
managing your time and I think that I'm
able to do that so well because I've
been a restaurant manager for 12 years
so I understand the scheduling and the
aspect that goes with that and I just
put that into filmmaking and my daily
life my favorite role in the whole
process is definitely post-production
editing I really like doing the visual
effects work but I also like cutting the
film together I think it's it's funny
how different things can turn out just
with simple cutting and editing so
that's definitely I think where the
magic happens and whether or not whether
or not your movies gonna make it or
break it
my least favorite part of the whole
process is the before I like writing
don't get me wrong but I think from the
coming up with the idea and then writing
it and then before you shoot like the
casting and the planning and finding
locations I want to give that to someone
else I'm not much of a planner and maybe
that's why my process works the way it
does for me is because I'm much more
let's just go do it I want to make a
movie I don't care what that location
looks like as long as we can do a shot
in it my process for casting
and following through with the cast I
posted audition notices on my overnight
pictures page my personal Facebook page
some people that I know would then share
it in like acting pages on Facebook that
I'm not a part of stuff like that just
get get out there as much as many eyes
as can see it so that we have the
biggest pool coming back to us so I got
I think the final tally was like a
hundred and twenty eight emails from
people that wanted to be a part of this
movie and I sent them back sides for
characters that I felt they looked like
so some people got two or three sides
some only got one some of them got the
majority of characters sides and they
sent back a video and I basically weed
out that way and from there we actually
had live auditions but the number had
been cut in half or less by that point
once the cast has been picked we do
table reads I kind of get on everybody
for weeks and weeks leading up to the
shoot and then I think my philosophy on
shooting so quick works because they
don't have time to get out of character
they stay in character the whole shoot
they're like boom ready to go the whole
three or four days when I post the
casting calls I actually include that
it's going to be only a three or four
days shoot you're gonna work 12 plus
hour days because that's what my work
schedule allows me to get off so I you
know I know some people the majority of
people will shoot a couple of days take
days off whatever take you know a month
long four weeks whatever it is but my
life and my schedule doesn't allow that
right now so it's
tough when we're shooting one of my
movies the way that it works is I
usually yell action and I let the actors
go and if they mess up they just keep
going and we'll usually get two or three
takes I try to make sure one of them is
a close-up so sometimes I might not be
getting exactly what I want and other
directors might want to shoot eight or
nine takes but I think for me as long as
you're getting one of everything that
you're happy with you're gonna be okay
because at the end of the day only one
of those takes is going in the movie now
you can cut it up and mix it up however
you want but really only one visual is
gonna go on that frame I think a lot of
people overcompensate for that because
they get eight or nine but it's like
dude you're only gonna put one of those
in your movie and if you're happy with
what you're seeing then there's no point
in going on especially when you're on
such a tight schedule in the past some
of my films I I see what they're gonna
look like and then they come out and I'm
happy with them but I'm not like that's
how I envisioned that to look
particularly with silver woods now
silver woods was shot in a day and a
half so that leaves a little room for
error like if you mess up it you pretty
much what we have to go on that's tough
but I would say it it's different with
silver woods and some of my other films
because we didn't plan out how things
were gonna look we had a story we had a
script we had a cast we had a location
but we didn't really get to do scouting
we didn't really get to set up what
things were gonna look like and it was
just kind of will play a by ear when we
get there and set up with pocket man and
cargo boy it was a little bit different
we did a little bit more planning we got
to see pictures of locations ahead of
time so we got to kind of plan out what
things were gonna look like but I would
say the biggest difference between Pocky
man and cargo boy is I wrote POC man in
cargo boy when I was 13 I've already
made Pocky man and cargo boy twice this
is the third time I'm making this
feature it's the time that I'm making it
the way I want it to look so I've known
what this movie and this whole series is
going to look like for a decade and to
be able to get the budget the actors the
crew the location the camera to be able
to do what I want to do was awesome I
have found myself upset with the footage
I have not done reshoots I've had to
work around it sometimes we don't get
access to the locations that we were at
because they were rented I've gone in
the way of finding places through like
Airbnb and the owners will let me use
the house or the the cabin whatever it
might be but five months down the road
when I'm editing and I'm not happy with
something I might not have access to
that place again for example when we
shot the October flowers the owner
actually sold the house a week after we
wrapped so I don't know that the new
owner would even let us back in there
and there's no guarantee that any of the
furniture would still be in there I'm
assuming they took all their stuff with
them so reshoots were kind of out of the
question I just kind of have to find
tricks through edit and fix it or cut
the scene entirely which I don't do very
often I usually figure out how to kind
of make it all work but there's
definitely times where I'm like oh we
should have done this why did we do that
my approach to how I handle actors and
crew on set is probably not very ideal
compared to how other directors might do
things my philosophy is always have fun
and make sure everyone is comfortable
because I believe that if they like what
they're doing and the environment is fun
they're going to give a better
performance have a better time and be
more understanding if you might fall an
hour behind schedule but it might not
work for other people if you're the
director and you're walking around and
you're this mean old guy that especially
the kids might be scared of or
intimidated by I think you're gonna just
the environment is gonna be different I
mean if you're gonna be working for 14
plus
hours you gotta like who you're with
it's no different than any other job I
would never go to a place where I got to
work a full day and my boss is just this
person that I'm scared to approach so I
directed man and cargo boy in a
robe and it was fun everybody had a fun
time and it was light-hearted and it's
different I know but it works I'm
actually self-taught in filmmaking
I grew up making movies in my parents
house that was my location that I had
access to so I wrote stories around that
idea and I think as I've grown I've been
able to get outside the box a little bit
I've been able to get locations go and
get forests and mountains and whatever I
wanted that my story was needing but I
think that that idea of being limited
early on has helped me out now
because if I find something that I'm not
sure how to do or don't have the money
for it doesn't scare me I'm able to well
look I made 50 short films in my parents
house growing up I can figure this out
the idea for paquimé and Kargil boy was
written when I was 13 living at home
with my parents but I was able to take
that idea as an adult and a professional
filmmaker and turn it into something so
much bigger but still following the same
idea I eventually did go to film school
I went to Collins College and learned
avid and got to play with some really
expensive cameras and that was nice and
it taught me networking but I think it's
important to understand that a filmmaker
can be by the books a filmmaker can be
someone who has all the experience and
knows every aspect of filmmaking and a
filmmaker can also be someone who's a
beginner that just wants to learn their
way because that's kind of how I started
I used to tell my friends one day I'm
gonna make big movies and people are
gonna watch them
they laughed you know I have always had
support but I don't think it's worth
adducts to go the way that I went but
that doesn't mean that you can't find
your own way you don't have to do what
everyone else is doing and conform I got
to go to film school I got to be a PA on
a big shoot you can do whatever you want
and you don't need a lot of money I'm
able to make all my projects for really
under 22 even sometimes ten thousand
dollars so it's not a ton of money being
thrown out there all at once it's
possible to make quality work with a
shoestring budget there's a difference
in being ambitious and being there's no
way in heck you're going to be able to
pull that off and you have to be clear
on that when you go in because if you go
into something knowing that you can't
pull it off you're gonna fail from the
start but I think that everybody should
probably take away the idea that just
because you're limited doesn't mean you
can't make something big